BETWEEN BARS DISCREPANCY.
>> Bret: IT CATHERINE HERRIDGE
LIVE ON CAPITOL HILL.
WE ARE JUST GETTING WORD THAT
JERROLD NADLER, THE HOUSE
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN JUST WRAPPED
UP A LITTLE IMPROMPTU NEWS
CONFERENCE WITH REPORTERS UP
THERE AND SAYING HE IS LOOKING
TO NOT ONLY GET ROBERT MUELLER
IN FRONT OF HIS COMMITTEE BUT
WAS REACTING TO THE NEWS.
JERROLD NADLER IS SAYING ALL
OPTIONS ARE ON THE TABLE.
THEY HAVE NOT ISSUED A SUBPOENA
AS OF YET AND THEY ARE ALSO
TRYING TO GET THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER IN FRONT
OF THE HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
ON MAY 15TH.
THAT IS TRYING TO BE LOCKED
DOWN.
BUT THIS IS A REACTION REAL-TIME